a
[Música]
ah
colombia registra más de 140 días de
aislamiento preventivo obligatorio una
cifra que le acerca a uno de los
confinamientos más largos del mundo
la cuarentena inició el 24 de marzo y
tenía que durar 19 días en un momento en
el que había tres muertos y 306 casos
cinco meses después continúa un
confinamiento que cada región ha
gestionado de forma diferente sin
conseguir eliminar del todo el kobe 19
pero si ganando tiempo para equipar
hospitales y unidades de cuidados
intensivos es llamativo el caso de
bogotá donde ha habido aislamientos por
documento identidad
por edad por género por comorbilidades y
como la que rige actualmente por
localidades con el desplegar media de la
economía y el empleo el gobierno ha
entregado ayudas desde distintos
programas sociales como el ingreso
solidario un pago de 40 dólares
mensuales a 3 millones de familias
vulnerables una ayuda que se extenderá
hasta junio 2021 por su parte en el
senado se han registrado cuatro
proyectos de ley para impulsar una renta
básica universal que cubra a todos los
colombianos
[Música]
en argentina la cuarentena comenzó el 20
de marzo y según la última extensión
anunciada se espera que llegue al menos
hasta el 30 de agosto cuando cumplirá
163 días es una medida que ha tenido
variaciones regionales y por momentos ha
sido más o menos estricta de hecho por
el nivel de actividad que hay hoy el
presidente alberto fernández dijo hace
pocos días que la cuarentena en
argentina ya no existe pero si siguen
vigente restricciones de todo tipo por
ejemplo no hay libertad total para
moverse entre provincias o ciudades hay
limitaciones para el uso del transporte
público muchos comercios no están
trabajando y no hay clases en las
escuelas esta cuarentena permitió en
argentina que no se llegara todavía a
saturar el sistema de salud pero también
ha tenido un impacto importante sobre la
economía que ha llevado al gobierno a
tomar algunas medidas de asistencia a
personas y empresas muchas no han
recibido para muchas no ha sido
suficiente y eso también ha sido motivo
de queja y preocupación entre la
población pero el resulta
o sanitario todavía es relativamente
positivo cuando se compara con otros
países
[Música]
pero estuvo 107 días en confinamiento
para contener la pandemia del cob y 19
pero el primero de julio las autoridades
del país declararon el del confinamiento
para reactivar la economía que quedó
dañada tras el largo encierro social el
gobierno peruano entregó ayudas
económicas para que las familias puedan
afrontar la crisis muchos denunciaron
que no recibieron los bonos de ayuda y
lo que es peor más de 6 millones de
peruanos quedaron sin empleo según
cifras oficiales pero fue uno de los
primeros países en adoptar medidas
estrictas sin embargo la pandemia el
coronavirus se está saliendo de control
según diversos expertos por eso el
presidente de martín vizcarra ordenó por
decreto supremo cuarentena focalizadas a
cinco regiones y 34 provincias son más
de 11 millones de peruanos quienes
volvieron al confinamiento con esta
ordenanza el mandatario quiere evitar
que más peruanos sigan muriendo pero el
sars cordobés no da tregua y también se
está llevando a cuidados intensivos a la
economía de esta nación el producto
bruto interno de perú ha caído 17 puntos
37 por ciento en lo que va de la primera
mitad del 2020